students in clark county will continue
learning from home
at least through early january that's
when superintendent dr jesus jarrah says
the board of trustees will take up the
next transition plan
meanwhile there are concerns within ccsd
about how students are struggling with
the change
some cases have even led to suicide 8
news now reporter
madison kimbrough is live in front of
ccsd with more
you know change really is inevitable but
for many students change during covet 19
makes it even harder to cope mental
health is very serious
it doesn't discriminate it doesn't care
who if you went to
coronado high school foothill high
school rich
poor black white asian whatever
it doesn't matter reggie burton knows
the pain of losing the mental health
battle
his son avery took his own life three
years ago after a severe bout with
depression
avery had just graduated from unlv two
months prior and shortly after avery's
death his father founded the avery
burton foundation
and wrote a book called this is
depression he wanted to help other
families understand what to look for
when loved ones were in trouble
they start to pull away they start to
withdraw from activities and
they find it very awkward to talk with
their parents
about what they're experiencing reggie
says he's not surprised students are
having trouble through the covet 19
pandemic
according to the coroner's office there
have been 14 reported suicides
for kids under the age of 18 years old
the youngest being nine
i don't want other families i don't want
other
parents to go what i went through i get
one call
text or email per week
from a person burton also mentions what
he calls a mental aid
action plan entitled algae a stands for
assessing the situation
l is making sure to listen g is to give
assurance
and e stands for encouraging self-help
through seeking out resources
now if you or someone you know is in
need of help you can call the national
suicide prevention lifeline it's right
on your screen
that number is 1-800-273-talk that's
spanish 1-800-273-8255 live from c-d-s-d
madison kimbrough
8 news now madison such an important
issue thank you